sexism isn't going to end until men
choose to end sex i feel like distancing
yourself from someone who you know is a
misogynist isn't enough it's about
realizing where you have access and you
have privilege and you have an
opportunity to just support someone
don't assume that you know already what
a woman needs wants and deserves listen
[Music]
introducing ben hurst my friend you are
the head of facilitation at beyond
quality i am you're an ally to me as my
friend give me the space to mess up give
me the space to talk about how hard this
work is and how i find it and i think
that allows me to
do the work better and be honest about
it introducing lancy fern okay lance to
me who is a musician
artist and someone who i feel has always
been an ally even without noticing it
which is something i always appreciate
about you i'm here introducing my friend
henry james garrett you get a full name
writer and illustrator you give me so
much hope like you are on like my
pinterest board of like
this is a good guy i just wish more guys
would like you
introducing marvin
hughes humes
my husband
you're my ally because you support me
you empower me you really help me snap
out of my imposter syndrome
what was your first experience of
misogyny when i was younger and i had a
my next-door neighbor
i should just hear like rambling
fighting screaming arguments and then
one day a woman is knocked on knocked on
the front door my mom answered she let
her in
and she was crying tears and she
explained to my mom what's going on and
it's not my personal experience by my
experience in this through this woman's
pain and i
quickly understood what was going on
like where it was if we had to talk
about
misogyny what is it that we're talking
about when we're talking about that i
think a lot about the difference between
sexism and misogyny because i think we
interchange those quite a lot
and i feel almost as if sexism is like
the ideology that like women are abc but
i feel like misogyny is the thing that
enforces that sexism misogyny as i
understand it is hatred towards women
and femininity that can be
like the active misogyny of like
violence and abuse and harassment or it
can be the passive misogyny that men
exhibit of um and being fine with
violence being perpetrated towards women
and girls and um fem presenting people i
always think of have you seen the office
yes uk one yeah yeah
okay um i always think of like that
scene where david brent's like
how can i hate women my mother's one and
to me that's what underpins misogyny
where is like that attitude of hatred
towards women and i think most people
don't walk around thinking i hate women
and then therefore most people think
well i'm not a misogynist because i
don't hate women because i don't
actively think it's right consciously
every day but i think it's the the
nuance or like the little thing that
underpins all of the things that we do i
feel like modeling taught me what
misogyny was funnily enough because
people will see the modelling industry
as a place where you can be free and
really expressive the way that sometimes
they would talk to women
talk to the young girls just telling us
that you know we're not worth anything
if we don't
basically bend to their will or a male
photographer will say like you're
nothing without me like you you know my
name my name's powerful in this industry
like i can end your career i was in the
girl band and you were in the boy band
you know four males were together and
five females were together but for the
females it was very very visual so
everything every article it would all be
about appearance the saturdays were
at our peak when it was still legal for
uh paparazzi photographer to be sitting
on the floor whilst you got out of a car
and entered a restaurant or a nightclub
or wherever you were i remember when the
early days of us being together i would
deliberately say you don't get out yet
let me come around to the side i'm going
to shield you as you step out of the car
which is disgraceful because there would
be those perhaps lurking to get that
shot that i hated going out without you
do you actually change the law right
yeah i did yeah i changed it because i
was at a festival
and i was wearing a skirt i hadn't seen
my sister in like a year and these guys
kept hitting on me and my sister and i
said like five six times like oh no i'm
good mate i'm with my sister and i'm a
senior and ages so i'm good and then one
of them is standing in front and i
looked around and he was like looking at
photo of my crotch on his phone and i
grabbed the phone like a run to the
security in the police yo that is wild
in and of itself and i got through all
the people and i handed the phone's
police and they were like oh there's not
much we can do uh if you chose not to
wear knickers would be able to do
something because it would be a graphic
image but you did so he can't oh my
fault sorry yeah next time i went with
him
and then i went home and then i like
researched into it and found out that it
wasn't a sexual offense upscaling wasn't
a sexual offense but it had been in
scotland for 10 years and i did this
whole campaign the mindset
if even if it is passive and it's not an
action it breeds a culture that enables
those actions to happen you know i'm a
white cis-hat woman so that threat is
multiplied depending on how many
insecting systems of a professional
you're sitting under so like friends of
mine like you know monroe bergdorf is a
black woman she also happens to be trans
and she experiences so much stuff that i
never even
so it's like you you think it's bad and
then you see that it gets worse and
worse for other people imagine like
being an ethnic minority woman that
we've got
everything's kind of against us if all
the other women are like the flowers
here the black women are like the dirt
underneath the grass there that's where
we're positioned in society as much as
people try and make it out like it's
anything else there's still a long way
to go that's why i say like safety and
respect is the thing that i want to be
different for women it's like a slap of
the misogyny and then it can be a back
slap or backhand of misogynoir
transmission you know there's like other
levels of class
um on sunday i was um coming home from a
friend's house and i was spat on for
being trans and uh these guys threw like
um a can of drink at us and it hit me if
you had said like to these guys these
young boys like no one's laughing leave
her alone like they would have because
like they're doing it to impress toxic
masculinity they're doing it almost as a
performance to other guys like it's not
for themselves if they were on their own
he wouldn't have said anything to me he
wouldn't have had the guts to he's
almost like performing masculinity the
awareness is is getting better and it's
great that you know you've spoken about
a lot recently and i've seen many other
women speaking about seeing men speak
about it and it's important that we keep
highlighting that the awareness is there
i think the mindset just needs to change
men are like this women are like this
and if you're not those things you've
failed at being a man or failed at being
a woman which like doesn't account for
the whole range of people in between
those two things on that spectrum or
beyond that who are going to exist
anywhere but are just going to live
under this difference
that they fit into and then for all of
us who maybe do feel like we fit into
those things there's also this big
performance to like keep up with those
ideas and i know for men those are
things like uh being strong being
dominant being in control making
decisions not asking for help all of
those things that like i would argue
don't actually come naturally to people
i mean i feel like those things are
learnt behaviors what was your first
experience of gender disparity so just
like the differences between how men and
women are treated in society in african
culture the woman does everything for
the man so my my dad would come have
come back from work get comfortable sit
down and my mom would go make some food
she'll fill up the the bowl of water
bring it right to where he's sitting so
he can wash his hands
that's the first thing i saw that i was
just like oh yeah like it wasn't wrong
to me it wasn't bad it's just like oh
yeah mommy does everything at that point
you're not seeing it as like
anything wrong or like you just you just
think that's the dynamic for me at the
time there was loads of stuff going on
and i thought i was going nuts like i
was like oh i'm losing it like i'm
crying in the toilet at work and i can't
control it like whatever's going on i
keep having these like emotional
breakdowns to then come to realize it
was completely normal like we just don't
talk about it as men you know i mean we
just kind of hide that stuff away from
everyone so i guess that was my real
like moment of transition and
interestingly for me that wasn't about
me wanting to be a good man for women it
was about me wanting to be the best
version of myself our idea of a man is
like
brave and strong and like makes people
feel safe
around him because he's a protector
right sometimes feeling things and not
forcing yourself to only express
yourself through anger and violence is
what allows you to be brave and maybe
bravery is you know calling out your
friends telling your friends that you
don't think that joke is funny yeah
because like that takes gumption i've
got a slightly different approach when
raising two young women than i perhaps
would when raising a young man you know
we are going to set those foundations in
the right way however when he's out of
our front door and he might be hanging
out with friends or you know colleagues
don't assume that you know already what
a woman needs wants and deserves listen
how do you think we move away from
gender stereotypes when we
when we're raising our kids i think
that's exactly it we haven't really got
those stereotypes we never put any
limitations on our on our children and
and you know you never should
i guess for me allyship is about using
your privilege
to dismantle other people's oppression
you don't have to be like an activist or
like have done you know read every bell
hooks book under the sun to be an ally
like it's about realizing where you have
access and you have privilege and you
have an opportunity to just
support someone this may surprise you
but i was i wasn't great and i think
it's useful for
guys to be reminded that that that is
true of almost any guy who's who's
trying that probably there's a time in
his past that he's not proud of right
because we're mostly raised to be sexist
um so so we're set up and and then
it is a process of of unlearning
at a certain point i know for me as a
man doing this work people in the
outside world look at me and herald me
as some kind of like feminist yeah we
talk about this a lot oh you're so great
and then i go home and i like hate
cooking like i refuse to
well i expect my partner to like wash my
clothes or just do dumb stuff that again
i like really learnt behaviors based on
the ways that i was raised i think
that's where the work really happens
that's where it really starts something
is important about disrupting those
things on an individual level i'm
motivated by the fact that like you can
have that realization you can't have a
moment that makes you go oh wait this is
actually
awful and
it's only men who can do anything about
it ultimately it's going to be
uncomfortable initially and like if the
barrier to you wanting to get involved
in ending violence against women and
girls and people of marginalized genders
is this barrier of like oh but it might
be a bit awkward and i'm jesus didn't
mean it your sister or your mom
shouldn't have to be like assaulted for
you to care you know it should be enough
that this is happening and it and it
should be worth discomfort as a man is
ignoring
or
distancing
yourself from someone who you know is
doing wrong is that is that enough i
feel like distancing yourself from
someone who you know is a misogynist
isn't enough when you could have really
stood up to that guy who said what
you're doing is wrong how you move is
wrong how you treat women is wrong how
would you say that men can be better
allies to women sexism isn't going to
end until men choose to end sexism
because like we can do all the work
start all the campaigns do all these
videos but like it's not going to stop
until men choose to stop so i think it's
really important to
be having that conversation about like
the nuance of like it's not just like
black and white you like can change it's
a conscious decision because men aren't
like like biologically ingrained to be
awful if the cause of their uh violence
is social then the solution must be
social exactly what is equality what is
true equality it's not a t-shirt it's
not a slogan or a catchphrase true
equality has given everybody the
opportunity to to shine and giving
everyone equal opportunity to do well i
know we've said it a lot but i think
listening is so key i think
really be there to nurture like you
would do someone that you saw yourself
in so you might do that with a young guy
that you think oh he's great he's going
to be amazing at this role i'm going to
nurture him to perhaps make him like me
one day and he can head up this firm
do that to a woman you know that's
that's the kind of
allyship we need to see
you